最终渲染出我们屏幕上看到的那个效果
而screen pass呢顾名思义就是基于屏幕的特效
它有点像后期处理技术
它针对的是整一张画面的一个处理的特效
也就是说对应于我们计算机图形学渲染里面的
来说
本质上就是一个像素着色器
就是一个一段pixel c的
就是对执行完的那个贴纹理或者贴图
或者是render target
再去执行一段我们要的PIZC的
那么我们今天的案例呢
就是说怎么在原来的基础流程上
在U1引擎的基础上增加一段简单的screen pass
那我们目标呢就是去实现一段简单的算法
那么比如说实现一些描边的效果
那就是拉普拉斯算子
就比如说实现一些高斯模糊啊
只诸如此类
那剩下的就是具体的算法好嗯
过程很简单哈
今天的内容会很短
因为这个东西确实很简单
我们看到代码嗯
我们要执行一段pixel shader
我们要考虑哪些因素
那当然是输入输出以及我们要写的着色器
假设我们要实现描边效果
描边效果
那我们自然而然就想到了什么拉普拉斯算子
拉普拉斯算子
就是说每个像素点跟它周围八个像素点
做一个加权平均
就是他自己的权重是八
周围八个是一
那么加起来
然后就是实现了描边效果
具体的呃原理我们这里就不讲了哈
你们去搜一下拉普拉斯算子就可以了
所以我们需要去写一段简单的PCC的
那么在U1里面写p cc的呢
就是像这样子写一个PX
那就是简单的这样子
比如说一个颜色如果是中心
那就是乘以八
周围就是乘以一
我们先写一段把这个东西
然后下面这个点层呢是做一个灰度
就是把颜色去掉
如果把这张做掉了
那就是还是有颜色
然后就是输出
那这个就是我们跟我们学DX一样
我们写完一段PX
那么我们的输入输出是什么
我输入我们希望是在原来的基础上
就是说我们把原始信仰
就是把U1现有的已经渲染出来的
最终的画面作为输入
再去执行我们这段PCC的
所以我们需要一张输入的纹理
也同时需要一个呃
采样器
那么算法很简单哈
这个算法非常简单
我们就不太多见了
那么我们这里呢就是会把它放到那个写完
我们把它放到引擎的seed engine c的
然后private就照着写就可以了
这里面有很多这些USF
我们照着引擎来写就行了
写完它
第二我们就要在代码里面去继承一个global seed
前面我们已经讲C加加里面的时候
我们说你要写完pic的着色器之后
你要去继承那个global seed
那第二步
第二步就是像这样
我们要去继承去实现一个global seed的类
继承这个类
那这个类并不用做太多太多东西
然后我们要声明用这个宏去声明他的参数
因为我们这里用到了两个参数是吧
一张纹理
一个采样器
那么当然我们就把这两个这个红通过了
这两个红我们前面讲过了
把这个加进去
那这个参数是什么呢
这个参数是U1已经做好的
它里面有非常多的一些我们常用的参数
我们非常方便
我们也把它加进去嗯
就是在代码里面我们计算UV
计算那个什么buffer size
那个这个东西的时候用不到它
OK好
然后再用这个宏这个implement said the type就行了
这里要注意的是
我们以前讲过
这里填的路径是没有SHADER的
什么意思
就是说我们这个路径看到没有
是engine到C的到private
但是我们去体验的时候是engine到private
跳过了那个C的
那这个是什么
这个是U1自己定好的规则啊
你这时也不用理
你
就照着这个规则的填就行了
然后填这个就是main px
就是PIZC的名字
OK把它填好好
那现在我们这个PX准备好了
我们第三步要做什么
我们要在延迟渲染的地方调用它
那么首先我们把整个调用先封装成一个函数
封装成一个函数
就是这个这样一个封装一个函数
就是我们先把整个到时候要去触发的
要到调用的东西
先封装一个函数
在头文件里面定定一个这样子的函数
到时候去适当的地方调用这个函数就很方便嘛
OK那注意这里我们要增加额外一个pass
就是一个复制的pass
因为前面延迟渲染
已经把最终的画面渲染出来了
它当前是目前的render target
我们同意将render target它不能又是输入
又是输出
但是我希望在原来的基础上去作为一个输入
怎么办呢
我们需要先把延迟渲染渲染出来的画面
拷贝一份出来
然后把拷贝的那一份作为输入
那么所以我们直接调这个这样那么很简单
我们用rd g的方法提供的方法
我们前上一节讲过
RDG直接创建一张贴图对吧
然后直接添加一个copy的方法
那么就是直接把当前the render target拷贝出来
那拷贝出来
然后现在我们就构造我们的这个参数
这个着色器的参数
那填好它
我们一共有三个参数
一个输入纹理
输入纹理就是我们拷贝出来的这张贴图
然后sample的
然后这个will挺好
OK然后填好就怎么样
然后就直接添加一个screen pass就行了
screen pass这些方方面的方法已经帮我们做好了
那么到时候就会在整个RPG执行完
那么先就会呃原始现养
到最后调一下这个函数就OK了
哪些延迟渲染已经先往出
渲染出以前的最终的画面
然后我们把画面拷贝出来
然后再跑一遍我们的peel seed
然后我们的peel seed是做了一个拉普拉斯算子
那自然而然就没有变色效果了
对不对
OK那就是这个效果
那到底在哪里去掉这个函数呢
呃最后一步延迟渲染的那个类似这个defy
这个大概是2000多行
所有整个你想要看原石现养的每个步骤
它就在这个函数里面
这个函数非常长
他大概从2000行到4000行
总共有2000行
然后函数里面又跳一段
所以非常好
非常长
我们一下子是说不了
讲不完那个这个函数
我们要慢慢的去分析它
我们今天先关注
不用管他前面已经做好了
我们就要调
那么当然在最后里面调
现在最后是3900多行
所以我们直接跳到3900多行
3900多行
二
我已经写好了哈
只是我注释掉
就是这一段
这个是我写好的
这个是引擎没有的
然后我们把它取消注释
就是对于每一个will遍历每个view
调一下我们的这个函数
调一下我们的这个函数就OK了
我们就可以看到它的效果了
那刚才那是是还没有调用
所以呢我们需要重新编译一下
重新编译一下
有点慢哈
嗯这么慢的吗
不应该啊
今天还用了一台厉害的电脑
我先让它继续编译哈
哦很快很快OK编译完了
直接debug执行
我们马上就会看到它就实现了一种描边的效果
OK看到没
整个场景现在就是出现了我们的那种黑白描边
就是这个效果
包括你跑起来也是一样的啊
那个是那个白色的区域
不用理哈
那个是我自己自己额外写的一个debug的东西哈
O那就是这样子就实现了
比如说我不想要描边
我想要模糊效果怎么办
很简单
我们稍微把这个
PCC的改一改
比如说是零点呃
1/9就是乘以呃
1.0÷9.0
是这样子吗
不管
OK那假设我们全部换成权重一
全部权重一样
那应该就是一个模糊的效果哈
我们直接跑起来看一下
是这样子吗
要不要加个括号呢
哦这一行应该要注掉
不然它还是白是黑白的
那那那是不是有点模糊
是不是变成有点模糊的效果
看到没有
我们拉近一点
还是有点模糊的效果
当然这个模糊的效果还不是高斯模糊啊
高斯模糊的权重不是呃
呃中间跟周围是不太一样的哈
并不是全部都是一哈
那这里就说明了呃
我们可以通过这种不同的算子
去实现各种各样的效果
而我们想要增加一个这样子的screen pass
也非常简单
那就是先写好着色器
然后继承global seed
然后实现它
然后然后在defending ller里面
在合适的地方加进去就OK了
那这个defending LLA呢
就是我们后面要重点关注的话
它就是原始现养的呃
大头目来的哈啊嗯没那么快哈
我们慢慢来
这个如果大家想知道原始信仰一步步做了什么
就是可以看这段代码哈
OK今天呢很短
就讲这么多